Here. Let me put it to you this way
Michael. What is MIMIC giving you for all of that
work that it's doing in building dependency trees and, and
you know, running Prim's algorithm and finding maximum spanning trees.
>> I'm going to say structure because that's
the word that you've been using repeatedly.
>> You get structure. And, and another way of
thinking about structure in this case is you're getting information.
You get a lot more information because you get structure,
you get a lot more information for iteration as well.
So, that's the price you're paying,
you're getting more information every single time
you do an iteration, at the cost of building this maximum spanning trees or
whatever it is you're doing in,
in estimating your probability distribution. So, why
would it be worth it to do that? What's the other source of expense?
>> Well, so, all right. So there's
all this computation within an iteration, but
what it's, what it's doing, what it's trying to do is trying to find inputs
that have high scores and so you do have to compute the
scores for all those inputs. So the, the fitness calculation is very important.
>> Right, so MIMIC tends to work very well when the cost of evaluating
your fitness function is high. So, it's
really important that I only have to take
100 iterations if every single time I look at a fitness function and try
to figure, compute it for some particular x, I pay some huge cost in time.
>> Well,
have you told us how many function evaluations there are in an
iteration? because it seems like, it could be a lot in MIMIC.
>> Well, you get one, basically for every sample you generate.
>> Yeah and, and so, but so. I guess,
you can compare iterations but you can also compare samples.
>> Right, so they would depend upon how many
samples you feel like you need to generate, and of
course you can be very clever because. Remember, theta
will generate a bunch of samples for theta plus 1.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So, if you keep track of the ones that
you've values you've seen before, you don't have to recompute
them. So it's actually pretty hard to know exactly what
that's going to be. But let's imagine that at every iteration, you
generate 100 samples. So, at most, you're going to have to
evaluate f of x, 100 times. So, MIMIC is still
a win over something else, if the number of iterations
that it takes is 100 or more than 100 times fewer.
>> Wow.
>> Right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, can you think of functions, fitness functions,
real fitness functions that might actually be expensive to compute?
>> Well, yeah, sure. I mean a lot of this stuff that is,
is important is like that. So, if you're trying to design a rocket
ship or something like that, that. Fitness evaluation is, is doing
a detailed simulation of how it performs. And that could be a very costly thing.
>> Right, actually it's, that's a good example because MIMIC has
been used for things like antenna design. It's been used for
things like designing exactly where you would put a rocket in
order to minimize fuel cost sending it to the moon. These
sorts of things where the, the cost really isn't evaluating some
particular configuration where you have to run a simulation or you
have to compute a huge number of values of equations and
so on and so forth, you know, to figure out the answer.
Another case where it comes up a lot is
where Your evaluation function, your fitness function, involves human beings.
>> Oh, interesting, yeah.
>> Where you generate something, and you ask
a human, how does this look, or does
this do what you want it to do because humans, as it turns out, are really slow.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah, they're not measured in megaflops.
>> That's right. So, you end up
with cases where fitness functions are expensive, something
like this becomes a big win. And that's
a general point to make, though, that when.
You are looking at all of the different algorithms, at different
models or at everything that we have been doing, both for unsupervised
learning and earlier for supervisor learning. A lot of times, your trade-off
is just in terms of whether you are going to over-fit or not.
It's whether it's worth the price you need to pay in
terms of, either space or time complexity to go with one model
versus the other. We've been talking about it in terms of sample
complexity, but there's still time complexity
and space complexity to worry about.
>> Cool. I
get it.
>> Okay, cool. So normally what we would do next is we would
say what, whatever we learn, but I actually kind of think we just did that.
>> [LAUGH] indeed.
>> So, in fact, let me do something about that.